so I want to take a minute to talk
about my first healthcare experience here in Austria
for context.
I'm a Canadian.
yes, there is free healthcare where I'm from.
however, the service is
getting a family doctor is basically impossible
if you don't already have one in Quebec,
you're on a waiting list
for no joke, 5:10 years
so to me was extremely shocking
to be provided with a company doctor
and my company
where it's private it's free
and she can fill prescriptions
and give referrals and stuff like this.
but even beyond that,
it's extremely easy for me to walk into any clinic,
literally you just walk in,
ask for a doctor
and they give you an appointment.
but so now to talk about the actual doctor
that I went to go see.
I originally just went to go see her
to get my prescriptions filled
and to get a flu shot.
I want to get a flu shot
because the flu is really bad here right now.
and not only did she go like
above and beyond
to try and find my matching Canadian prescriptions
here in Europe
because I do have an e card now,
so I'm covered here.
so obviously
I rather get my prescriptions here
than pay for them in Canada.
so beyond the fact that she went above and beyond
to help me with all of that,
she actually took the time to like,
check in with my mental health
and ask me about any previous health issues
and stuff like that.
even though I didn't bring anything up.
and we got on the topic
of my migraines
and my mental health
and, you know,
period cramps and stuff like this
nausea and just things I've experienced
when I was younger.
and the fact that I switched birth control
5 times in my life
to try and make my period symptoms better.
and we just talked about all of this
like super nonchalantly.
I guess because she was trying to refill
my birth control.
and I was trying to explain
I did not want to switch again.
and I was just shocked
to have her bring up
endometriosis.
so it has been years
that I've suspected
that I have endometriosis.
I have just about every single symptom
that's on the list.
but in North America
it's impossible to diagnose
unless you get surgery.
it's very invasive.
it's basically a biopsy.
they have to go in and get a piece of your
I don't know what that is in English.
basically they get a piece of the skin
and then they test it.
and because it's so invasive.
it's like, well,
what's the point.
and she was telling me that
there's actually a gynecologist here
that's specialized in a certain procedure
that's just an ultrasound.
and so he has a really high tech system
where he can detect endometriosis
super non invasively with an ultrasound.
and so she gave me a referral
and I'm finally gonna be able to go do that.
I'm just really grateful
I moved to a place with good healthcare.